[Música]
un nuevo bloque de economía en directo
américa de france24 daniela blandón ya
nuevamente conmigo en el estudio van y
vamos a eeuu porque en ese país baja el
desempleo pero suben las vacantes bueno
entonces se conoció la semana pasada que
el desempleo en abril cayó a su mínimo
nivel desde que inició la pandemia un
3.6 por ciento también es un mínimo en
los últimos 50 años sin embargo hay un
fenómeno muy llamativo que se viene
repitiendo mes a mes a raúl y es que las
vacantes están en un máximo histórico de
11,5 millones es decir hay dos ofertas
de trabajo por cada desempleado porque
hay 59 millones de desempleados y es que
hay algunas pequeñas empresas todavía
tienen dificultades para contratar una
encuesta de comansa que revela que entre
1100 microempresas el 90% enfrenta a
esta situación y la mayoría asegura que
es porque las grandes compañías están
atrayendo a los empleados con mejores
salarios y beneficios un ejemplo de ello
es que si bien la mayoría de las
principales industrias ya ha recuperado
los puestos de trabajo perdidos por la
pandemia el empleo en el ocio hostelería
si se ha reducido en 15 millones o un 87
por ciento desde febrero del 2013 danny
también los países del g7 acordaron
vetar gradualmente el petróleo ruso ya
cambiando de tema claro que así estos
países son canadá francia alemania
italia reino unido japón y eeuu todos
alineados hoy contra rusia por su
invasión a ucrania este grupo se
comprometió a prohibir o eliminar
gradualmente las importaciones de
petróleo ruso pero esa definición deja
la puerta abierta para no hacerlo
inmediatamente este es el caso de japón
que dice que lo hará pero se va a tomar
su tiempo
energy y siguiendo es una decisión muy
difícil para japón que depende de las
importaciones de petróleo como recurso
energético pero es el momento en que la
solidaridad del g7 es de suma
importancia según la declaración de los
líderes del g-7 esta vez se decidió
tomar medidas para embargar el petróleo
ruso en principio y japón tiene la
intención de continuar trabajando de
cerca con este grupo para mantener el
orden internacional
danny también eeuu puso más sanciones
contra rusia y que se trata claro pues
mientras la unión europea no se pone de
acuerdo en el veto al petróleo ruso de
eeuu que si lo hizo hace varias semanas
impuso más sanciones restringió las
visas de un grupo de más de dos mil
personas prohibió también a tres cadenas
de televisión comprar tecnología de eeuu
y decretó que las compañías de su país
no pueden prestar servicios de asesoría
financiera a personas oa entidades rusas
entre otras medidas el kremlin se ha
mostrado resiliente a estas sanciones al
menos en lo que al valor de su moneda se
refiere porque en términos de
crecimiento si reconocen que la economía
se va a contraer entre un 8 y un 10 por
ciento ahora veamos desde el comienzo de
la invasión el rublo se ha fortalecido
inicialmente se desplomó y ahora están
un poco más de 65 rublos por cada dólar
esto está muy cerca de un precio mínimo
de 2 años que tuvo frente al dólar hace
pocos días y esto se debe en parte a que
moscú ha impuesto controles de capital
que limitan la capacidad de las empresas
rusas para enviar dinero al extranjero
además ella sede tampoco también tienen
que convertir el 80% de sus ingresos en
rubros indicadores económicos raúl el
china que es la segunda economía más
grande del mundo mostró que sus
exportaciones en abril crecieron pero no
tanto como en marzo y eso golpeó las
principales bolsas asiáticas en el
comienzo de esta semana en europa además
del debilitamiento de la economía china
también las bolsas siguen en rojo por
afectadas todavía con la subida de tasas
de interés en eeuu y para finalizar
danny que nos trae como cifra el día
volvemos a rusia 300.000 millones de
dólares en reservas internacionales que
tiene
país congeladas en occidente según
cálculos del ministerio de finanzas
ellos creen que son un poco menos de la
mitad del total de reservas que tienen
en oro y divisas y es que de acuerdo con
el financial times el jefe de la
diplomacia europea josep borrell propuso
confiscar esos recursos para financiar
la reconstrucción en ucrania esto ya se
hizo por parte de eeuu con el dinero del
banco central afgano para resarcir a las
víctimas del 11 de septiembre jan y como
siempre gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos mañana con más y
estoy seguro que se iba a llenar esta
vez a donde nos vamos a parece a parís
claro que sigue ahí está nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz vamos allá